and welcome to this video playing champ
Busta sham pasta Stefan christensen
Icelandic gem okay let's see it's going
to play Knight to g5 he isn't okay yeah
the good old JUCO piano see going for
something with g4 it's um an entra para
enterprising way to play this or maybe
he just wants to get the nitrogen three
okay maybe we should be six getting this
traded on getting d5 in okay i can i can
just take and play define i mean is they
are drawback i don't see it at the mood
I can go naija 50 this is stupid I have
to play h6 first of course hmm it hurts
a little bit
that's bad oh it doesn't do it Wow why
not not if I look good okay here i'm
just very comfortable I mean no problems
at all like it's just better here a
little bit maybe maybe maybe not if if I
take on b3 of air Queen takes I mean he
at least text be seven ok have good
other useful moves my ticket Queen takes
Queen III Queen B seven this some keeps
things about equal rupee aid us a really
lame move okay maybe pile up on the D
file the thing is he has a week depot
and simply and it's something that I can
play against it it's nothing terribly
serious but it is it is in the position
night if for I am this is IDM or
possibly Queen h5 move like that it's
just important that I if he goes 94 I'm
not taking this night I mean I can take
it it's not like totally crazy but I
don't intend to do that i was thinking i
can just move the Queen somewhere Queen
g6 for example yeah why not so that you
cannot move the night because of mate at
least not to see 5 or anything like that
he can take d phi f play queen bee three
but even have Ruby five then could be
tricky in this rocker but okay
yeah I going for kind of a self pin but
he can always trade so what now I can't
read I can't read myself he he threatens
to check on g5 and play Knight f6 check
it's not so great
I take b3 I source of the s95 in this
pollution
maybe this movie the knight on c6 is not
great anyway if he takes Knight takes
this is certainly an improvement and I
also like to play b6 controlling the c5
square maybe and b6 I couldn't do before
because of the capture on d5 and Knight
f6 winning the exchange so this prepares
and the whole thing if I'm really really
ambitious i can think of Bishop c6 but
his Bishop has a good diagonal so it's
something that should be considered very
carefully is not threatening 95 at the
moment
maybe this actually trying to trade
trade the Queen's and if it's not
trading I have night to g64 night f4 so
it's probably yeah advisable for him to
trade okay yeah 96 is a is a way to
continue this ok I will do that I don't
like to block the default but its own
it's a solid choice maybe he can play
something like f for him mm-hmm okay
yeah at the end he will take be 74
interesting and four nights and 95 later
I don't really think that this should be
so bad for me but I feel like I did
something in precise earlier okay I have
to do that I guess yeah I could be
tricky it really could be check check
this night c5 Willa check the porn yet
again and very very difficult situation
time morning high five I don't know if I
can play 96cm it could be could be
trickier for a passer b4 c4 okay I
cannot calculate it I simply cannot how
do i get some counter play against his
pawns let's activate the King first then
see what I can do here night to
survivable come yeah I am a porn downham
I have what if we had game what about
yet game I really don't unless I did we
don't think that this was like anything
for white I think I just had an
advantage but I spoiled it somehow
yeah is pushing his pawns it's really
dangerous not sure though if he can
promote everything without the king but
okay of course the chime it's not
helping very much trying to go to g6
check check check okay black resigns
haha that it was that was really a
really complicated I mean this is just a
good structure for black so I can never
be worse really it's just a question how
to play this correctly how to play this
correctly computer is very much no
nonsense about it it takes here trace a
five and says black a slightly better
yeah that's probably true if I get in
like b6 I can prevent a snide from
carrying to c5 and he just has this week
porn on d3 I mean it's not like he's in
big trouble a this is just one weakness
that can be defended easily but I mean
black is certainly just okay here this
is what I did b6 is again good a5 is
also good but this is not good job it
just the the pressure here is a little
bit its mounting a little bit too
quickly yeah and then it's really it's
just concrete stuff f4 and now my queen
said I'm just lacking exactly one movie
i'm liking a move like a five when I had
a five in then I would be six here and
I'm just okay again but this is like
just concrete libreria I have no no move
now to prevent my queen side from
falling apart so this was surreal
problem may be here I can still maintain
a playable position king of a it seems
to be better yeah that's that's one of
those technically focus moves yeah like
here he cannot take because he's
trapping his own night okay I understand
but the real problem was this this night
night 37 okay this wasn't bad I have to
play bc
see I have to really really prevent
nights 95 this is just okay for me
nothing nothing terrible happening here
you can do stuff like that like this and
there may be here it's just I don't know
it's just a normal position yeah nothing
going on if he manages d for you
certainly can equalize him but this is
the best that what can do of course yeah
very interesting it is just very
concrete yet this this kind of thing
here yeah i was i was seeing it here
yeah that this f4 can be a problem but i
didn't see it before him and that made
the difference in this game when he
played a form he's really a check
tearing down my my defense and here here
i have no way to defend this I was
thinking briefly I come let me do this
but i think the the key important game
should just be winning and also he can
do that and just go here now it's a win
anyway he should just play this night
end game it's winning he will win ponce
FYI what size is gone him yeah they
played as well he played that really
well i mean he didn't play the opening
one this was supposed like really bad
for white but um it turned out that it
it wasn't wasn't that terrible it's
still it's still fairly solid white
white is not in any huge trouble but i'm
satisfied i played this all right and
this is this is in fact much Tim player
this is this idea it also has one added
advantage it fixes this weakness only
three eyes so it cannot play before so
that's quite good okay but you played
well um thanks for watching